[Música]
y seguimos celebrando la leyenda de
freddie mercury daniela cuál era su cuál
es su canción favorita the queen
bohemian rhapsody puede ser muy de
guayaquil cualquiera de esas muy bien
dan y esto en el marco de los 30 años de
la lamentable partida de freddie mercury
por aquí lo estamos celebrando ahora sí
hablemos entonces de economía le
pregunto qué están haciendo las grandes
potencias para frenar el alza en los
precios del petróleo para volver a
hacerlo de otra celebración dos meses
nos atrás al aire también dos meses al
aire de este programa que no se enamora
cada día y que somos felices de
acompañarlos o todas las mañanas aquí en
directo americana ni el es verdad ni que
pasarlo por alto ahí arriba nos espera
una torta para superar la lista de los
hombres bueno muy bien claro que sí pues
ahora sí hablemos de petróleo y de
economía porque mire los que se unieron
le va a dar la lista eeuu china india
corea del sur y reino unido- estos
países pretenden liberar parte de sus
reservas estratégicas de petróleo para
estabilizar los precios de los
combustibles que están disparados a
nivel mundial específicamente 50
millones de barriles en el caso de eeuu
que también culpa a las gasolineras de
espe con los precios este miércoles a
este grupo que le acabo de mencionar se
unió japón escuchamos
hemos estado trabajando con eeuu para
estabilizar el mercado petrolero
internacional y hemos decidido vender
parte de nuestras reservas nacionales en
coordinación con eeuu tenemos de facto 8
de manera que no contravenga la ley de
reserva de petróleo japonés existente
daniela y usted que también explica toda
la economía mundial como puede esta
alianza enfriar los precios del crudo
mire raúl los precios del petróleo se
deprimieron en pandemia porque la
demanda se paralizó y ahora que se
reactivó los precios están en alrededor
de 80 dólares por barril y con tendencia
a seguir subiendo pero los países
exportadores agrupados en la opep más su
socio rusia no han querido atender el
llamado de abrir el grifo para
estabilizarlos
usted sabe cuál es la ley de oferta y
demanda entre más oferta haya pues van a
bajar los precios entre menos oferta
vaya pues van a subir los precios
entonces lo que hace este grupo de
países liderado por eeuu ahora es poner
más barriles en el mercado y de esta
manera presionar los precios a la baja
así es danny y bueno vamos a hablar
ahora de méxico porque el presidente de
ese país se quedó sin candidato a la
gobernación
-banco central- que pasó el 31 de
diciembre de este año culmina alejandro
díaz de león como presidente del banco
chico que es el banco central de méjico
y el presidente andrés manuel lópez
obrador había propuesto al senado que su
reemplazo fuera el ex secretario de
hacienda arturo herrera pero se conoció
que desde agosto pasado cambió de
opinión sin darlo a conocer y sin
explicación alguna como lo explica el
mismo arturo herrera en su cuenta de
twitter en la que confirma que
efectivamente el mandatario le informó
hace una semana que había decidido
reconsiderar su nombramiento ahora ni le
pregunto por qué entonces ha sido tan
polémica esta candidatura
raúl a los bancos centrales son
tradicionalmente autónomos su tarea es
dominar los costos de los préstamos o
sea las tasas de interés y controlar la
inflación en el caso de méxico giros
inesperados como éste podrían inquietar
a los inversionistas que siempre han
desconfiado de la politización de la
autoridad monetaria y que pasó en
turquía que hoy no se pueden comprar
ciertos artículos electrónicos pues si
ustedes tuvieran porque en este momento
no podría comprar una porque porque mire
los turcos que intentaron comprar este y
otros dispositivos electrónicos en línea
recibieron mensajes de error este
miércoles incluido el sitio web de apple
esto después de una caída histórica del
15% en la moneda local que hace que
estos productos estén más baratos de lo
que están en eeuu o sea que a estas
tiendas pues no les conviene vender allí
aunque en la sesión de este miércoles se
recupera la lira llegó a caer hasta 13,4
dólares el más a 13.4 por cada dólar el
martes y esto reflejó un mínimo
histórico por una décima sesión
consecutiva en lo que va del año esta
moneda ha perdido más del 40% de su
valor algo parecido a lo que ha ocurrido
en venezuela niega que también estas
grandes empresas estas grandes tiendas
se han ido porque ya no el negocio
evidentemente está en un país con una
evaluación es tan alta bueno en
venezuela hablamos una locura más al 525
por ciento pero le pregunto a qué se
debe la devaluación específicamente
volviendo al tema de turquía que al
volver los economistas lo atribuyen a
que el presidente receptor erdogán está
defendiendo los recientes cortes o
recortes bruscos en las tasas es que ha
hecho el banco central y esto nada
contra la corriente del resto de bancos
centrales del mundo que lo que están
comenzando a hacer es a retirar
estímulos para frenar un poco el consumo
y de esta manera controlar la inflación
esto ha creado un fenómeno raúl también
mire lo que interesante la gente está
comprando ciertos activos como los
teléfonos celulares con la esperanza de
venderlos un año después a un mejor
precio por supuesto es que lo mismo
ocurrió en venezuela pues o pongolle
obviamente el ejemplo porque me tocó a
mí vamos ahora daniela con los
indicadores las acciones asiáticas
operaron mixtas el miércoles en el radar
del mercado siguen estando desde luego
las preocupaciones sobre que la reserva
federal pueda empezar a subir tasas de
interés las bolsas europeas por su parte
cotizan en rojo con las mismas
preocupaciones e influenciadas también
por el repunte de casos de kobe 19 y
empezó con deuda daniela porque nos va a
ver la cifra del día para el próximo
bloque de economía aquí en directo
américa así que ya nos vemos vamos ahora
con nuestro segundo reportaje del día
porque no se prevé todo el día pues no
nos atendió vamos a ver si lo podemos
tener en más adelante nuestro programa
esta gente